nothing happened we just started long
distance and we had to say goodbye today
and i'm sad jojo siwa is missing her
girlfriend
kylie prue the reality of long distance
it's very very very hard but it's the
most worth it ever on monday the 17 year
old entertainer posted this image to her
instagram story
in tears writing on the photo i don't
like saying goodbye
fans grew concerned that something bad
may have happened
so jojo took to her stories to clarify
why she was upset
reading comments on my last post and
you guys are confused i was crying on my
last story
and i just got clarified nothing
happened we just started long distance
and we had to say goodbye today and i'm
sad
it happens every time we say goodbye and
i wish we didn't have to ever but we do
and
it just makes the when we get to say hi
to each other even more special
i'm gonna go keep doing this for a lot
longer uh
i'm just gonna come in here because i
know you all were panicking for a second
but no need to panic
the reality of long distance it's very
very very hard but it's the most worth
it ever
but before the gals had to say goodbye
they spent a lot of quality time
together at the happiest place on earth
disney world i love that that's my
favorite thing ever
in one clip the couple shows major pda
hugging each other on the vintage
amphicar as they dive into disney
springs
and on splash mountain they got close
once again
kylie putting her arm around jojo giving
a thumbs up
to the camera in january jojo came out
as a member of the lgbtq plus community
and a month later jojo revealed she was
in a relationship during an appearance
on the tonight show starring jimmy
fallon
it is true i do have the most amazing
wonderful perfect most beautiful
girlfriend
on their one month anniversary jojo
introduced kylie on instagram
describing her as the most loving
supportive happiest
protective and just the most beautiful
perfect person
in the world a similar sentiment she
shared during her speech at the 2021
glaad media awards
i have the best most amazing wonderful
girlfriend in the entire world who makes
me
so so so happy and that is all that
matters
i think it's really cool now that kids
all around the world
who who look up to me can now see
that loving who you want to love is
totally
awesome and speaking of jojo's fans the
pop star will turn 18
in may and despite growing older she
promises
at least for now she's still the same
signature
jojo everyone is like you're gonna be 18
are you going to change the show
and i'm like no people are coming to see
me and my unicorn they're coming to see
me and my big bow they're coming to see
me sing with bobo they're coming to see
me living on a rainbow bridge that's
what they want to see
give them give the people what they want
you know everyone wants to have a good
time and a good night
and i think eventually you know i will
grow up past that and i think cobb the
unicorn will have a lovely garage in my
house one day and always be a part of my
life and i think my front door will
always have a hair bow on it
it's who i am